hey everyone my name is Fergus early I'm
product manager on Google Play focus on
app excellence a general blade I'm
chenille do i'm CEO of Halfbrick Studios
great and we're here to talk to you
about five new products we're announcing
at this year's google i/o to help you
achieve a better operating on Google
Play so what we found through a lot of
data analysis feedback from users
feedback from developers is that there's
two major components to achieving a high
rating on Google Play what is technical
app quality and the other is listening
to users and interacting with them to be
able to have them feel that you're
giving them what they need and having
good experience so first we're going to
jump in to improving your technical app
quality last year we announced at cloud
test lab and as you here today with
Jason in the keynote we now have
firebase test lab which has run since
last year over a million tests on real
physical Android devices in the Google
Data Center running developers like
yourselves apps and if you haven't used
it so far go ahead and go to the
firebase test lab today and start using
it you can use it from Android studio
you can use it from the firebase console
are you can even use it from the command
line would in play we've had an
integration where you don't have to
write any custom scripts and we will
give you a report back of how your app
performs on 10 plus physical devices and
we're now updating that this year with
the pre-launch report before I jump into
what exactly is in the pre-launch port
hands up if you have an app on google
play today okay and keep your hand up if
you tested your app on more than 10
physical devices where your latest
version that you pushed up okay i'm
impressed with some people here now keep
your hand up if you are able to get
those results in those 10 devices within
an hour okay we got one person that
spotify down the back is impressive and
and yet i'm here to show you how all of
you can have your hand up to that
question if you're ever asked again so
with the pre-launch report we have three
sections today crashes section
shows you how your ass performs when a
robot is interacting with it for about
five minutes on real physical Android
devices representing a range of devices
and form factors and here you can see
that we show you over time how your
latest versions are impacted by the
robot interaction with them you can see
that four or five three a few older
versions ago that wasn't doing so well
and vast majority devices were
experiencing a crash and with the latest
a few versions it was doing pretty good
until the last version which had two
crashes detected as you scroll down this
part of the report you can be able to
see the details on the devices that were
tested you can be able to click on any
device and you can be able to see the
stacktrace if there was a crash the loud
cash the device configuration a video of
the robot interacting your app and lots
of other information to help you with
actually fixing the issue that has been
detected now we know this all the
developers in this room never have
crashes so we talked how can we make the
reports still valuable for you guys and
so we are introducing the screenshot
section where you can we show you
usability issues that are potentially
occurring what your app so here we show
you what your app looks like on
different android versions different
models different screen sizes different
screen resolutions and even different
languages so you can be able to see if
there's any issues when your app runs in
arabic in right-to-left language you can
see when you're going for the emerging
market you can see what your app looks
like in Hindi when you're going to look
at languages that have longer strings
like German you can be able to see what
it looks like in those and as you can
see in this example here there's a
layout issue that's occurring in German
and I'd encourage you to have your
designers go through and have a look at
these results as well because this is a
really valuable for them to be able to
see what the app looks like on all these
android devices would not much work for
them the final part of the pre-launch
report is the Security section and this
is where we put Google security team to
work for you and where we show you known
vulnerabilities that we detect in your
application before you launch it out to
the one point
two billion Android users for developers
who don't have lots of resources and
want to be able to get quick testing
this has been a really valuable resource
for them now it doesn't replace all your
testing but it's a really good way to be
able to enhance your existing QA and
testing of your application as the flink
team has identified to be able to get
access to the pre-launch report you just
need to go to the Play Developer console
click on the pre-launch report tab which
replaces the previous cloud test lab in
the Play Developer console and you can
click to opt in from that point on when
you upload an abk to your alpha or beta
channel will generate a pre-launch
report for you within an hour of
uploading your apk and and so yeah we
think that this is really really
valuable in the past we found that sixty
percent of the top house maps on player
already running alpha and beta channel
at testing and if you're not doing it
today we'd highly encourage you to do so
great so the pre-launch report fits into
the before you launch your app and
trying to figure out if there's any
issues with it but as you all know it's
always that there's issues that occur in
the field and that's where we have tools
now for live in production too so as
you're rolling out your app you should
use to age rollouts if you don't already
and this is where you can be able to
roll it out to one percent five percent
fifty percent of your play audience and
be able to see how you new and existing
users are experiencing the latest
version of your honor and as you do that
you should be able to monitor your crash
reports we encourage developers to use
proguard to be able to obfuscate their
code when they release a navy k if your
are a pro guard user you can be now it
be able to upload your proguard mapping
file to the Google Play Developer
console and have your stack traces d
obfuscated it for you when you actually
go to look at any crashes that I've
occurred out in the wild as you hear
Jason today in the keynote we now have a
full cross platform crash reporting tool
for iOS and Android called firebase
crash boarding this is part of a much
larger suite of analytics and
notifications so if let's say sunder is
using your app and he experiences the
crash then you can be able to see
how his engagement in your app has
changed and you can be able to send him
in notification when you fix that issue
that he's experiencing this is
completely free and I it's available
starting today so if you use this your
proguard mapping file that you upload is
part of play will also work for the
firebase crash reporting all you have to
do is link your account so we've gone
over in terms of technical a quality the
pre-launch report before release and
when you're live in production the crash
reporting part i'm going to hand it over
to ricardo to talk about the new three
tools that we have available for
customer interaction cool so Fergus told
you how you can focus on improving your
up technical quality with the tools to
the red nose while listening to your
users is equally important and we could
say you know the customer is always
right so you should really focus on
listening and understanding what your
users are telling you to make your
application great but it's not only a
matter of making your users epi it can
also have a significant impact on your
performance of your rap game the popular
games to do they focused on improving
the quality of one of their app from 3.1
3.3 stars to 4.1 and over the same
period they observed that their revenue
increased by one hundred and sixty
percent so this is pretty significant
and a good incentive to make your
applications great aviary tells us that
is never too early to start collecting
feedback from your users even when your
app is still in development even when
you're still not live and these can have
a significant impact on your development
speed your iteration speed and how
quickly you can you can launch your app
in production so for these with a few
announcements to make the first one is
I'd like to announce early access in
Google Play so this is a new program
that allow users early adopters to find
apps with are still in development
straight from the Play Store as part of
the early access if you are using an
open beta if you're running an open beta
even if your app is still not in
production users will be able to find
and opt into your app to your open beta
straight from the store listing page of
your app in the Google Play Store
and this is a great way also to start
collecting early feedback from these
users and help them help you give you
improve your quality of your app
collected early feedback while you're
still developing your app and really
make it great for the moment you're
going ready to go to production in fact
until now it was the case that if you
write we were running and a private beta
or an alpha and beta users would not be
able to review or rate your app as part
of early access users will be able to
write a private feedback it is directed
only to you developers and it's a way
for your early adopters to give feedback
on now you can improve your app while
you're getting ready for your launch
they can go to the Play Store to your
store listing section and just leave
feedback there it's private it does not
affect your overall operating is
available only to you on your side as a
developer you can go to the Play
Developer console and you will find that
in the ratings a review page there is a
new section which is called beta
feedback in here you can find everything
that you're early adopters have shared
with you and you can use filters and
search to a bit navigate through these
feedback and you can reply to them to
start engaging in a conversation with
them so we hope this is going to be a
great way to increase the amount of
early feedback that you get while your
app is still in development so let's add
another tool to what we mentioned so far
beta feedback very helpful we expect we
hope as one of the tools that you will
use while you're still in the early
development phases of your app at some
point you're ready to go to production
and now the game changes you're going to
get a lot more reviews a lot more
feedback and it becomes important to be
able to sift through these reviews and
early identify what matters where you
should spend your attention what are the
bits that your users are telling you
that are really important and so we have
a few more things to help you out with
this first as you already know in the
writing section of the developer console
you have access to an indication of your
overall operating historical trends how
it is changing over time
and drill-down sin breakdowns for now
your rating changes across countries and
across application versions but what we
really focused on is making the reviews
part even better we really want to be
able to capture the most of what your
users are telling you and make it
available to you in the easiest way
possible so we have a few things to
announce first in the reviews part of
the developer console you will find
highlights highlights are salient
snippets that we have extracted from
user reviews they are available to you
in the developer console and they are
also visible to your users straight from
the Play Store in your store listing
page they are a great way to understand
what capture your users attention and
also what signals users use to decide
whether to install your application or
not one you think that you will find is
topics again in the reviews part of the
developer console what we've done is
very using machine learning and natural
language processing to look at all the
reviews that are being submitted for
your app and identify peculiar topics
that are specific to your app for
example if you're a language learning
app you might find that your users find
really difficult to learn klingon or
they might comment on the quality of
your spoken translations or the
availability of an offline mode for your
app if you are a current racing game
people make comment on the quality of
the graphics or the difficulty of the
gameplay for each topic that we identify
you will be able to observe the
distribution of ratings and the volume
of reviews that mention that specific
topic and also we give you an indication
of how big of an effect user reviews and
ratings on that specific topic of on
your overall operating so the more the
red the bigger the opportunity that you
have to really focus and addressing your
users concerns on that specific topic
and increase your overall operating and
we hope this will be this will be a
great way to help you prioritize your
attention and really focus on the things
that matter most for your use
but we have one more thing we also have
benchmarks so what we did again we use
machine learning to look at all the
reviews that have been submitted in the
Play Store for all the apps and we
identified eight common trait common
aspects that we think pertain and can be
quantified for any up in the store from
its design its usability the stability
and bug of the apps disability bugs the
speed of the app and for each of these
topics we quantify how you score on
those topics what is your rating on
those specific topics and again how much
your users are talking about these
aspects and as I mentioned before you're
given you get an indication of where you
should focus your attention with the
factor rating which tells you where you
have the biggest opportunity to capture
a good chunk of your rating score back
Groupon was one of our testers and they
have great feedback to say how much it
use it helped them prioritize their work
and focus on what really matters but you
don't really have only to trust our
words we can look at some data so one
thing we did we did is we looked older
English reviews in the Play Store where
we could identify at least one topic and
here is what we found for all the
reviews that are one star in fifty
percent of the cases people will be
complaining about the stability and bugs
of the app for all the reviews that are
five stars sixty-five percent of your
users will be praising the speed design
and usability of your app you can go to
the developer console and look at what
the data looks like for your app and we
think that this is going to be a great
way for you to understand maybe where
you are you're letting your users a bit
down and on the other side where your
app is really really shiny and will be a
great way to improve your operating okay
so this is great now you understand when
you should focus your attention what
your users are telling you the next step
is to start engaging in a conversation
with them because having an active
conversation with your users can make a
real difference
with filters and search functionality
you can drill down from the topics and
benchmarks that I mentioned before the
specific reviews that contribute to them
and once you have identified a review
that you really need to take action on
obviously you want to reply to your
users because it's really important to
start addressing their feedback but one
thing that we announced a few weeks ago
is the ability to be notified whenever
one of your users update or change their
review as up after your reply and this
is a great way to stay in touch with
your users and the ones that are willing
to engage in a conversation and it can
really have an impact in fact we've sent
great adoption over time as of today
forty percent of play top developers
have enabled this feature to be notified
whenever I one of your users to which
you replied to comes and update the
review so you can stay in touch with
what they're saying so if you're not
using yet go to the developer console
today give it a try you will start
receiving emails and notifications
whenever your users change the review so
you can stay on top of things engaging
with your users in an active
conversation and replying to the reviews
is really important it's a crucial part
of your app quality users are really
expecting these for em from any
developer these days and in fact we've
seen great adoption of the functionality
of being able to reply to your users
reviews over time ninety-two percent
growth year-over-year the Guardian
popular newspaper in the UK considers
replying to reviews and invaluable part
of their customer management experience
so if you're not replying to your users
yet go ahead and start doing that
because I'm pretty sure all of you want
a bunch of five-star lawyer lists for
your app as well but replying to your
users from the developer console can be
quite cumbersome if you have a ton of
reviews and we have heard from many of
you that you would like a way to be able
to deal with your customers at scale so
starting today with a new API available
among the API is part of the Play
Developer experience that lets you fetch
and reply to your users reviews with
just a handful
temple of lines of code if you're not in
the mood of writing a couple of lines of
code we also have integrations zero
effort available out of the box with
some of the most popular customer
management solutions out there like send
us and convert social so if you're using
then that's for example you can just go
to your Zendesk account with a couple of
clicks link it with play and start
receiving your reviews directly in
Zanders integrate them with your flow in
their reply from there and see them be
propagated live in the play store within
seconds responding to your users let me
say once more is really really important
here is another data point we noticed
users that come and update their star
rating after you have engaged with them
after you have you responded to the
review on average increase their star
rating by point 71 stars and this is
pretty significant because it's the
difference between a four-star up and a
4.7 star up which can be really really
massive so we covered a ton of stuff so
far from one year still developing your
app to run your life from telemetry and
crush reporting to managing user reviews
I would like now to have channel it's
the CEO of house brick creator of great
it's like Fruit Ninja and Jetpack
Joyride give a demonstration of how
they're using the feature in their own
world thanks for qatar hey guys i'm
going to give you a few demonstrations
of how we're using some of these tools
that half brick just to give you guys
some idea of yeah I guess what I'm
trying to do with you know I guess
reviews and customer service at half
brick we have a goal where we try and
have all about apps at 4.5 stars or
greater so it's a pretty lofty goal and
I guess it's one that we r you know
trying to find new ways to sort of hit
okay thank you so I'm going to show you
how we're using the zendesk integration
as well as the pre-launch reports and
the reviews analysis tool so on who uses
n desk here for
their customer support okay and who
actually replies to their Google reviews
okay a lot of people that's really great
so you know one of the things that i'm
going to show you is I guess how easy it
is to sort of pipe in all of your google
play reviews into Zendesk and then
actually reply to them so i'll start off
by creating a new review for Jetpack
Joyride so let's go ahead and do that so
I'm filtering out four and five star
reviews so i'll give it a three star
review hopefully this will come through
so let's see how we go i think it's
worth more than three stars by the way
okay so for this particular one oh I'll
just put in a review to say I'm addicted
to this game and but but
I'd love to say my high school's I love
ok
so let's submit that
and I guess it can take a little bit of
time to submit it but then it'll take a
little bit of time to come through into
Zendesk as well and if it doesn't I have
a backup one that I've created
previously so let's see how we go
ok
all right maybe I might go to the pre
generated one let's see that I got a
second okay so this is a review that
that we put him previously and is and
it's come through to Zendesk so what
I'll do is so those of you that have
used in desk and set up macros that
allow you to reply real easily so I've
created one previously which is
so okay the review that I put in was
about saving saving high schools so this
this pre-populated one is about how to
actually do that so we'll just go
through will submit this is pending
and then
we will click through to the Google Play
Store
look
and as you can see the response that I
put in previously has come through
straightaway so you know talking to our
our customer support agents one of the
things that I stress to them is I want
them to reply to pretty much every
single one star review that comes in and
they were doing a lot of this manually
themselves but after using this for one
week you know one of the quotes they
said was you know one of the statistics
that they really look at is that first
touch time statistic and they said you
know when this feature came through
their first touch time statistic for the
initial week I was implemented was still
within their KPI which is less than 24
hours so they were able to handle I
guess all of their existing volume of
support requests which is quite quite a
number i think jetpack has over three
million sort of reviews as well as lots
of tickets to come in but they managed
to handle that as well as respond to
google play reviews or within 24 hours
so it's a really really amazing feature
and our guys really love it so i guess
that's one side of the equation which is
actually responding to reviews and
tickets as they come in the other thing
that's really crucial for us is to
actually analyze the reviews and as part
of trying to hit 4.5 stars we've created
a whole bunch of tools that are guys use
to actually try and make some sense of
the reviews that are coming in so as I
mentioned jetpack has a lot of reviews
every day so if we jump across to just
give me a second here yeah that one's
frozen
if we jump to the developer console so
okay so if we go to the reviews and
ratings as you can see here's the
reviews analysis tab so as Ricardo
mentioned there's a number of things
here I mean there's the review
highlights which is really good to see
it gives you a quick sort of idea of
what's going on with the app but the
thing that's more important for our guys
is the benchmarks because you know it
really just goes to show you which areas
of your app you know I guess they're not
doing so favorably and as you can see
here stability is obviously you know one
of the biggest factors and I guess the
stats that the guy shared clearly shows
that so I mean stability is one thing
but it's you know it's hard to figure
out what it is exactly i mean you can
look at crash reports and various other
things but this tool really allows you
to drill down you know quite easily so
we can look at obviously you know click
on stability and see and see the various
reviews that come through so there's a
number of different reviews i think one
of the things that I really like is the
fact that you can you never see filter
these and once again one of the go tues
is to look at the one star sort of
ratings so if you look here most of it
will be based around various various
crash issues you can see our guys are
actually replying to all of these
reviews so 17th of may I think that was
yesterday they're just going through and
they're responding to all of these so
most of these reviews are okay the thing
is buggy and that's that can only tell
you so much so one of the other areas
that's really interesting is the topics
that people are talking about and I know
that with star skater in particular when
we released it one of the key issues
that we had was around the controls and
so you can see here that actually
controls is the number one factor that's
affecting our ratings so once again you
can jump in and
can have a look at control issues as
well so the filter that I put on is
already there the one star you can go
through and have a look at all of the
different issues that people are having
with controls and you know sometimes
people just say okay that control suck
but other times you'll find some really
useful information in here as well and
and it really allows our guys to hone in
on I guess the key things that are going
to impact on improving the reviews so
once again out we have internal tools
for this but you know these tools in the
developer console just save us so much
time and particularly for our larger
games are there so many reviews it's
really hard you know we don't have the
the I guess of machine learning to to
process all of that information and give
us the key insights so it's a really
good tool and and I think you know we'll
see over the coming months how it just
helps us reach our target at 4.5 stars
so okay the last tool that I wanted to
show you is the pre-launch report and we
have an internal QA team at half brick
and the way they work is they wait until
I guess a builder's been submitted or
uploaded before they start testing and
one of the first things that they do is
a smoke test and so we can't cover like
10 devices you know within a within a
short amount of time so this has been
really really helpful for us so you can
see here the latest build that they
uploaded of star skater had a problem on
the you know Nexus 5 with Android
version 5.1 so Nexus 5 with Android
version 4.2 was fine but obviously you
know the problem was with 5.1 so this
saves a lot of time our guys don't even
have to start queuing until they get a
bill that sort of passes you know passes
some of the key tests on these devices
so similarly similarly with the
screenshots one of the other tools that
we really invested a lot into was how to
go about supporting all the different
aspect ratios and form factors of
devices so might switch to another app
here
let's look at dan the Man which is still
in soft launch so quickly jump to the
pre-launch report so crashes no crashes
which is really good screenshots so we
can have a look and see the various
screenshots and the different form
factors so you know obviously this is
something that you can mess up quite
easily I don't think we currently
support languages other than english at
this point so we're not really getting a
good read on that but we can see okay we
can you know all the aspect ratios look
pretty good all the different form
factors look pretty good so once again
this sort of saves a lot of time and we
did build these tools internally but
they're not integrated into I guess
everything around the developer console
so you know it's not as efficient for us
to use so the last thing and this one is
I guess really important for me because
we have our issues in the past with the
security for some of our apps and and
typically these are some of our older
legacy apps which we released the last
update months and months ago and now to
come back and actually fix those
security issues is a real nightmare
because you know the code base has
changed so much and you have to get the
thing rebuilding again so being able to
upload and get I guess a security scan
to say everything's okay is great
because you know if there is something
wrong you can fix it then and there and
not have to come back to it you know
months down the months down the road so
this is another really important feature
that our guys use all the time okay so I
guess that's a quick overview of some of
these features my my main sort of
feedback really is that these can help
you really raise the quality bar for
your apps and you know the resulting
user reviews that you get so you know I
highly recommend you check them out get
familiar with them and try and use them
as not
you can it'll save you a lot of time and
allow you to hit your ratings goals that
you set for yourself so thank you might
hand back to focus thanks
great thanks very much janu i it's
always great to hear it from a developer
because as the app and tool creators we
kinda are a bit biased so thanks for
neon so we've gone over five different
tools today and I really encourage you
to take advantage of all the pre-launch
report for early on development cycle
and when you're building that latest
version of your app use firebase test
lab then last sanity check pre-launch
report then when you're actually in that
phase as well start doing beta testing
and have your private communication
one-to-one with your beta testers and
without that impacting your star rating
then once you've launched start using
firebase crash to monitor your app out
there in the wild to see if there any
are any crashes that are are impacting
your users and be able to see what it
what crashes are actually the most
impactful to the business metrics that
your care about so you can be able to
prioritize which crashes you fix the
reviews analysis really helpful to be
able to understand the reviews at scale
and your functional areas within your
company so your designers can go in read
all the reviews about design the person
is going to work on the crashes and
stability of your app going read all the
reviews talking about crashes what I
happen to go through all the reviews to
find those ones about crashes and the
reviews API so your customer support
team can be able to use their existing
workflow of whatever customer support
tool they use initial partners or
zendesk and converse social but I'm sure
many will follow to be able to respond
to your reviews right there